ah
I kind of rolled my eyes when I heard
they were making a Maleficent movie I
mean it just seems like a pointless
thing to do
Maleficent is a great villain one of the
great villain she's so charismatic and
evil and loves every minute of it at his
elegant and clever and diabolical she's
given just the right amount of screen
time in the original seating beauty so
the idea of learning more about her past
didn't seem too bright but at the same
time I was open to it
I guess when the film finally came out
it became very obvious what they were
trying to do it's the Wicked formula
again trying to take a fairy tale we all
thought we knew and tell it a different
way where the bad guy doesn't look so
bad when I figured that out which you
can't very quickly in this film I just
sort of shrugged and said whatever just
give me some pleasing eye candy it
didn't I didn't think too much of it but
then later when I really thought about
it it's hard to piss me off
like really piss me off I thought about
what they were trying to do to one of
the great villains one of the great
Disney icons turning the mistress of all
evil into a simple case of
misunderstanding turning three of the
most likable comic relief's into these
idiotic morons turning an iconic Disney
fairy tale that has its flaws but was
still pretty damn creative into every
other poorly CG stale story that comes
out about fairy tales nowadays you know
what this movie really sucks a lot we
start off with the backstory of
Maleficent as a little girl who
apparently had wings originally okay
this is because she was a fairy all
right well she looks kind of cool so
we'll go with it she then meets a human
boy and they grow up falling in love but
then he finds out when he's older that
if he kills Maleficent he'll be given
unbelievable power but he can't quite do
that because he's too nice I guess so he
decides to cut off her wings instead she
decides from this day on that she hates
all humanity and is just gonna be evil
years later the King marries and
eventually has a daughter and you know
how this goes Maleficent comes to the
party curses the daughter and says when
she turned 16 she'll prick her finger on
a spinning wheel and die once again the
fairies are called in to take her away
and waste
but get a load of this Maleficent always
knows where the baby is and because the
fairies are too stupid to raise a child
Maleficent actually kind of raises her
herself cuz you know she's not so bad
after all
once the child grows up she eventually
bumps into Prince Charming they fall in
love and all this time Olympus and is
not only watching but actually getting
on pretty good with her because yeah
this is what we want to see one of the
greatest villains of all time having
Girl Talk talking about feelings
chilling laughing having all sorts of
fun fucking my watching if I like gets
to a point where Maleficent does and
what the princess to die so she knocks
out the Prince and tries to get them
back together because if she does fall
in love that pricks her finger maybe he
can wake her up and meanwhile the king
has gone crazy just because any vows to
set a trap for Maleficent yeah kind of a
shock he didn't do that before so it's a
battle between Maleficent the hero and
the princess's father the villain yeah I
can tell they really got the idea about
what Disney's Sleeping Beauty was all
about I won't give away what happens in
the end but remember what they did in
frozen with the true love thing and how
they did a little bit of a twist on it
yeah they do that here too except it was
already done in frozen so it's not
really a twist anymore
I guess there's one or two good things
in this some of the visuals are a little
neat most of them are pretty standard
and not rendered very well actually
Jolie was pretty cool as Maleficent
she's got that devilish smile and a cool
look here there but while our acting's
not really bad it's not really anything
that great either the actor playing the
King is awful I mean really bad I guess
he's supposed to be like this really
complex character but he just sort has
these weird mood swings and out of
nowhere goes nuts and none of it's
convincing and it all sounds so silly
they brought me back a day to CID I told
all three idiots lock it up in her tit
something about his voice I can't
explain it I don't know if it's the
inflections or the pitch or whatever but
he just annoys the crap out of me
she's only sleeping why am i and
everything else like I said is trying to
turn this story into something
isn't which okay wicked did something
like that and once upon a time did
something like that and they seem to
work out okay but that's part of the
problem
they already did it if you're going to
do it now you have to add something
really new or really groundbreaking
wicked have good writing and characters
and music outside the fact it was a
twist out story we already know this is
just so standard and not only that it
takes characters that you already loved
and instead of making them charming in a
new way it just sucks out anything that
made them unique the fairies good god I
mean there's dumb and then there's just
insultingly dumb it's almost like the
writer of this movie just didn't like
the person who created the fairies
originally or something and just really
wanted to stick it to them I mean they
are just so terribly written I know this
is done so that Maleficent looks more
like the star but come on this is
downright degrading and like I said
Maleficent herself is just not that
interesting I guess this could be kind
of a neat spin seeing how we all know
the story and yet it is kind of juicy
with her getting her wings chopped off
and eating all humanity and stuff and
trying to go through a change but
nobody's written with any charm or
charisma I give the actors credit that
they're trying to add charm and charisma
but there's just so little to work off
of nothing about a cries that somebody
had this great idea and really want to
tell this story in a brand new way that
was gonna just change the way you look
at everything it's obviously just trying
to do what everybody else is doing and
in the process it insults some of our
greatest Disney characters but fairies
were awesome don't try to make them
stupid
my lumpin said what's great don't try to
make her good the Kings were charming
don't try to make him this asshole
I don't know if you want more reasons
why I hate it go watch the honest
trailers of it I guess if you're just
looking for something that's kind of
pretty a touch create that they remind
you a little bit of those classic fairy
tales then it's a harmless waste of time
well if you're looking for something
that's gonna suck you in and you can't
wait what's gonna happen next and it's
very psychological and intriguing and I
don't know anything not stale and hasn't
been done a million times then you can
definitely give this one up